e Olha ele aí
e aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo
bom com vocês
em todo o vídeo vai ficar primeira vez o
que que você demora tanto a fazer vídeo
entre sabe por quê Porque vocês não
clicam em gostei aqui em baixo adianta
ficar falando que aí você não faz mais
vídeos no vídeo passado a imitem o md
chefe para clicar no gostei e vocês não
clicaram igual nos outros vídeos
anteriores
2016/2017 vocês não me ama mais seu
próprio centroavante já foi uma
tendência
do velho tá passado você não me ama mais
você está fraco na fé não está deixando
a oferta do like aqui na igreja mas hoje
eu quero que você deixa Deus tocar o seu
coração que você clica em Gostei do
momento apropriado na hora apropriada
que você achar mas que Deus toca seu
coração se você tiver uma conexão com
Deus se você não gosta de Deus você não
vai ficar em gostei e olha eu vou falar
aqui fogo dói ai ai ai ui ui que fosse
você não clicar não gostei lembrar vocês
também que quem não comprou o meu livro
ainda é também não vai para o céu porque
está escrito aqui na paz Eu sei só que
não controle no WhatsApp
E aí me pergunta esse negócio não tá com
pão em você sempre responde cara é muito
interessante você fazer uma coisa que
todo mundo diz assim não vai não você
vai morrer as pessoas você vai morrer eu
me sinto assim um paraquedista sabe com
tanto faz aquele o povo faça isso não eu
sei que vai abrir mas a pessoa tem esse
puxar essa cordinha e saiu umas panelas
lá onde eu moro aqui é bem alto sabe
aqui é o
cobertor os prédio prédio é uma coisa
aqui também me deixa muito pensativo eu
fico pensando como foi que a galera
decidiu Né tava indo indo indo aquela
falou assim galera encheu é um passeio a
primeira pessoa que dessa ideia né Vamos
fazer uma em cima da tua casa maluco não
pensa comigo eu faço um negócio em que
eu subo e moro em cima janela se deixa
de ser sonhador aqui eu morando no topo
da ideia de João Nelson volta no assunto
eu moro no vigésimo muitos andares Caio
caixa veio aqui uma vez sabe que eu
morava era bonita ficar traspassado
pelas duas aí na sua pegar nele fazer
Olha que legal esse
abelha paraquedista e aí olhando aqui de
cima nossa casa daqui de casa colocar
alho muito a altura
aqui agora faz sentido que tem medo de
altura aquele que não está com os
paraquedas nas costas o único meio de um
paraquedista sobreviver é com paraquedas
paraquedista né que é vista só que ele
não para nada só cai porque o
Whindersson lutar com o popó também não
sei não acho que eu tô indo em busca de
resposta o porquê das coisas é uma das
coisas que me move para ser quem eu sou
fundamento por trás da parada é o que me
dá vontade de fazer o que eu faço o quê
que eu gosto de cantar porque eu acho o
mecanismo da voz de tudo que envolve a
música e senti muito irado também
e foi nessa que eu descobri o
[Música]
meu primeiro morro de verdade na minha
cara saber que vai levar um amor mais
forte que eu já levei na minha vida eu
não fui nocauteado mas o meu olho toda
vez que eu apertava ele assim com força
fazer assim lá dentro Eu juro por Deus
assim ai ai ai ai que eu
olhava para esse lado tava tudo certo eu
olhava para esse eu dia tudo torto assim
e fala meu Deus de loucura minha retina
o meu amigo perverso tem uns carinha
desse tamanho que se você procurar
confusão com ele Nossa saída do Villa
Mix você tá enrolado primeira saraivada
de pancada que eu também na academia foi
do menino parecendo o Smilinguido Depois
desse dia foi que eu quis aprender a
lutar porque eu esqueci macho olha o que
o ser humano consegue fazer comigo caso
ele queira Tava não eu quero saber como
é que faz para não pegar esse meu jovem
lateral que você não sabe lutar logo eu
virar as costas eu levo na barriga
porque o cara desaparece da tua frente
já solta a mão na tua barriga aqui ó não
dá você deita aí você pensa assim não da
frente a tia do cachorro quente não o
Jorge e Mateus terminando tocado Não não
quero eu sou bom eu seria um ótimo
lutador só que agora já tô velho para
começar a ir porque não tem um bom nome
de lutador nas ter um bom slogan o amor
de prédio por quê Porque dói pedra Toy
uma pedrada na cabeça
meu filho tá prendendo do ano se for um
paralelepípedo famosa pedra de
calçamento a não Whindersson Nunes são
de que comediante ja ta engraçado o
Whindersson Nunes Seu nome é um atrativo
muito interessante Wesley Safadão vai
tocar a inclusive no dia do meu da minha
luta com o pó Wesley Safadão o nome dele
é Wesley Oliveira Mas quem vai no show
do Wesley Oliveira Oliveira agora dia 36
Janeiro Light music show Wesley safadão
tá doido já me sinto no show do Wesley
Safadão
e olha vai ter fala Matheus que é o
Windows sem vou dar um abração para você
tô aqui do show do Wesley safadão só mas
lembrei de você aqui em tamo junto Valeu
obrigado obrigado
obrigado Deus jogando Oi Rafaela que eu
ligo se divertindo para carai preciso
ter um bom não se meu nome fosse o
Whindersson das Neves aí é ser Hype que
eu ia botar meu apelido de O abominável
aí quando eu nocautear se alguém meu
amigo até o narrador EA ter vontade de
dizer assim ó
e
fala entra no clima porque é para viu a
história do lutador brasileiro é sempre
muito sofrida se eu fosse lutador meu
irmão pode prestar atenção todo lutador
tá 10 anos tentando sai o campeão você
vê o carro rasgado você fala assim
[ __ ] deve tomar suplementos alto
coloquei o com uma mão gelada que eu vou
macarrão com salsicha nos carregados na
vida e outra na luta vai mostrando a
carreira dele como ele era antes meu
irmão ele há dez anos atrás não tem nada
a ver com ele agora parece ou toda dor
trabalhar levou tanta pancada na vida a
tomar passar você poderá ser Olha eu vou
dar esse ver a cara do Eduardo Costa é
muito sofrimento aos 70 normal com 16
anos com 20 anos você tá passando
Tartaruga Ninja asileiro é coração pô o
cara ganha o cara chora Manda um abraço
para mãe vai ficar minha mãe dona Zelina
quando a mãe de lutador Oi Adelina é
Célia ou Sida não é como um sussurro só
se entrar no octógono e dá dois tapa na
cara da mãe dele foi de vó mais forte
grita para ele o autógrafo pensando se
nem minha mãe me ama para quê que eu vou
amar o próximo eu vou pagar sai meu
amigo esse esse irmão e nove esses que
terminam sei o quê não sei o quê bom
menor é esse gol 69 viu meu Face e
brincar com o menino desse aí na saída
do do Árabe Mix fumo começa falou pela
massa o cabo no chão que você fica que é
isso para que isso cara violento quer
arrancar a cabeça do coleguinha para que
isso amigo aqui tá todo mundo aqui no
entretenimento brincando assistindo você
vem querendo rapariga que você aprende o
Whindersson lutando tanta tanta coisa
seu cérebro fica rápido eu preciso de
rapidez que eu faço piada o cérebro é
feito de caminho criado por seguir o
caminho e você vai rápido até ele tá não
posso meditar que eu durmo É porque você
criou o caminho a primeira vez você vai
de toda dormiu agora Toda vez que você
medita você dorme igual botar barulho de
chuva para dormir eu boto barulho de
chuva e tu então onde eu tiver aí chover
sono se eu quiser dormir eu durmo porque
é o caminho criado se eu quiser quebrar
esse caminho preciso ser o que aprendi a
ter personalidade pelo sou o que eu sou
e esse é o melhor que eu posso fazer eu
sou um artista mas isso é uma forma de
me expressar tudo é uma arte marcial é
uma forma de arte que eu associo o estar
vivo a saber se expressar quando você
não sabe se expressar você não vive de
guarda tudo para você a sociedade vive
da forma que quer e você nunca está
inserido e nunca pode inserir ninguém
que você não externa antes disso você
fica parado no tempo você fique NET fica
em loop você trava que eu não tô
crescendo tem que eu não tô vendendo
mais que não tô fazendo aqui a partir do
momento que você aprende a se expressar
e depois disso Aprendi a ser
compreendido é a partir daí que você
vive de fato a primeira vez que eu acho
que eu me expressei de fato entende o
que era isso vai quando eu botei uma
peruca na minha cabeça fiz um personagem
interpretei e passei o que eu queria
passar naquele momento eu me agradei
porque eu soube que eu era muito bom
naquilo e eu entendi o que eu tava
fazendo porque a maioria das pessoas
fazem que não estão entendendo partir
daquele a minha primeira apresentação eu
falei puxa é de o ser humano precisa
disso precisa rir precisa de um ou e
depois eu comecei a me perguntar mais
coisas que mais o ser humano precisa
Como eu posso fazer parte de A partir
daí porque eu comecei a viver e pensando
nisso eu pensei em criar uma hashtag
para você contar Qual o momento da sua
vida você aprendeu a viver com a hashtag
Há quanto tempo você vive esse aqui não
é uma publicidade Sou eu mesmo que quero
saber a quanto tempo você aprendeu a se
expressar de fato vai no Twitter usa
essa hashtag me conta a sua história
deixa eu ver poder com a minha equipe
que são meus amigos e a gente vai
selecionar as 10 melhores histórias e
mandar um monte de presentes os
presentes Não sei vou ver ainda eu não
entendo dois caras lutando Nossa não
entendo entende mesmo que não é isso
dois caras lutando isso aí pode fazer
qualquer lugar qualquer momento foi meu
irmão desce do carro pronto dois cara
nunca vídeo no WhatsApp aí obrigando pau
de briga dos caminhoneiros duas mulher
da moto Olha briga agora só não é isso é
tática estratégia da academia eu vejo
que o gordo batendo bombado mulher
batendo no homem e respeito que você do
meu corpo desde sempre assim eu já fui
por dia eu já pensei 106 kg e eu sempre
gostei e sempre Adorei ser como eu era
de todas as formas de todos os jeitos e
eu sou muito fã de mudança corporal
adoro gente que muda muito para poder
fazer um filme virar outra pessoa e
nessa de aprender eu tive uns
probleminhas de saúde então eu comecei a
unir o útil ao agradável Precisava mudar
alguns hábitos e eu precisava faltar na
minha cabeça e já essa questão do que
muda de forma quando quer e como quer
mas para isso precisava entender como é
que funciona a máquina que é como se
fosse um carro nosso compra perfeito se
você cuida muito mal da Ferrari ela não
não vai ser mais o desempenho da Ferrari
se você cuida muito bem do Golzinho
então Paulo gostoso isso não quer dizer
que é você ser forte você magro não é só
Realmente você entender que as vezes é
preciso dar um carinho do seu corpo pode
ver a vida inteira até mesmo de Malhação
e loucura é você Tá exigindo demais
enfim esse mundo junta tudo e dá uma
sensação que você faz em alguma coisa
legal eu acho que o esporte salvou a
minha vida muitas vezes sabia tipo assim
eu já me aliviei muito treinando tava eu
descobri que meu corpo libera coisas
quando eu faço alguns exercícios
entender racks do corpo humano que você
vai aprendendo para te deixar bem esse
mundo não é fácil não tu não é fácil nem
para mim para que para mim é mais porque
moro na crista do raio então fica mais
fácil mas não é fácil Tem muita coisa é
tudo muito diferente é uma era muito
diferente a gente não vive há 20 anos da
mesma forma a gente vive há 20 anos com
tudo mudando todo tempo e às vezes você
precisa encontrar conforto até na troca
de encontra mais felicidade Quando
consegue perceber alguma coisa além da
que você tá vendo duas pessoas brigando
se fosse duas pessoas brigando era muito
simples Até um monte de coisa de
envolvida tem um monte de por quê Porque
eu indo só ela tá com qualquer que o
Whindersson quer chamar atenção quer ser
mais famoso já tá ruim e vai fazer uma
coisa diferente quantas dessas coisas
vocês pensaram aí vocês me assistir há
tanto tempo vocês me via tanto tempo
vocês olham para essa luta e vocês ver
uma coisa assim simples ou vocês veem um
trabalho de muito tempo indo para um
lugar muito mais uma projeção muito bem
feito e muito planejada dando tudo de
mim como sempre foi sempre sempre foi
assim você não consegue perceber que o
pó não tem o mesmo prestígio como é que
faz ele tem que ter que não percebe que
um monte de criança podia tar lutando
boxe em vez de tá fazendo uma coisa
errada mas não tem esse exemplo na
televisão representatividade essa que
vocês falam eu vou dizer para vocês é
muito difícil acreditar um você é muito
difícil acreditar na gente mesmo pai eu
tô com você para tu tá nada tá comigo
para tudo até para quando eu lutar box
ou só para quando eu for gravar meu novo
show e você quiser raypa comigo lá
sentar lá perto hoje eu tô no meu máximo
no puro né no puro eu tô no meu máximo
que tem usar de ti quem sabe ativada e
você meu amigo fica parecendo aqueles
francão que sabes Frangão grão-para
gênico Frangão que vem na tua direção de
falar e bater hoje eu no puro no máximo
que eu aguento tô assim assim o máximo
que eu
em alta performance sabe passar por um
que o lutador passa Eu exijo tanto do
meu corpo que eu vejo que tem um limite
eu aprendo isso falar olha só eu não são
a
e eu não sou homem de ferro e aí você
descobre quem é que tá com você para
tudo mesmo que nem fala até o fim quem
acredita no seu esforço todos os
projetos que você faz eu tô aí mano tô
sempre fazendo documentário para vocês
aprender o que eu faço podcast ansa
música que vocês estão sempre pelo que
agrada vocês que aquilo que vocês
acredita e eu vou fundo do que eu
acredito eu acredito muito que essa luta
com pó vai ser uma coisa muito massa de
serviço não esquece de clicar em gostei
aqui se você acredita em mim primeiro
link na descrição do vídeo é o site
music show você pode assistir a luta
entre eu e Popó do conforto da sua casa
lembrando que se este vídeo tiveram
muitos cliques em gostei o próximo vídeo
vai ser esse aqui ó tá deixar a dica dia
trinta de Janeiro Fight music show eu
quero que você comente aqui embaixo Há
quanto tempo você vive quê Porque quando
foi que você teve um estalo de agora
você sabe que você veio fazer aqui nessa
terra eu vim fazer tudo
Vivendo muito até eu morrer hoje eu
falei o quê Park Jurassic Park